Adnan Syed is speaking for the first
time since his murder conviction was
overturned as an appeals court in
Maryland weighs a possible redo of the
hearing that led to his release Syed
spent more than two decades in prison
for the 1999 murder of 18 year old hymen
Lee before he was exonerated but now
Lee's brother is arguing that his rights
as the representative of a crime victim
were violated Elaine quijano has the
story
we're really grateful for everybody
Adnan Syed is once again fighting for
his freedom Thursday the family of Haman
Lee the ex-girlfriend Syed was accused
of killing in 1999. Asta Maryland
appeals court to reinstate his murder
conviction and hold a new hearing on
whether it should be vacated in a brief
lawyers for Lee's brother who lives on
the west coast argued he was given less
than one business day's notice of the
September hearing that triggered syed's
release they added that prosecutors did
not provide enough detail for him to
understand or fight the evidence
supporting their bid to vacate the
conviction we take no position as to
whether or not Adnan Saeed is guilty or
innocent what we do take a position on
is trying to substantiate the rights of
the victim and the victim's family here
Syed who was 17 when he was arrested
spent more than 20 years in prison
the case gained International attention
after the 2014 hit podcast serial raised
questions
the 41 year old was released last
September after an investigation found
evidence that could have cleared him was
withheld from the defense including two
other potential suspects they should
dismiss it because there's no criminal
case anymore Erica Suter is syed's
attorney I think that he and his family
and I are afraid of the possibility that
he could be returned to prison we
definitely understand that Hayes family
is suffering and I just it's just that
we suffer too it's not clear when a
decision will be made for CBS mornings
Elaine quijano New York